What are your thoughts on me doing a three day water fast?
So three day water fast, the only negative, we've talked about this a lot, that the only
negative about doing more than a 24 hour fast for cancer patient is that your IGF1 levels
go up.
So if that's a benefit, if you don't have cancer, so do it along her fast like three day water
fast once a month for a person who doesn't have cancer, that's really beneficial.
You want your IGF1 levels to go up, that can help, things grow, that can help you rejuvenate
things, but it's generally considered that you don't want your IGF1 levels to go up
when you have active cancer.
So it's generally recommended that you don't do anything more than a 24 hour fast if you
have active cancer.
The only, the only exception to that would be if you're going to do IV chemotherapy.
We recommend a 24 hour fast for doing before your IV chemotherapy, but some people recommend
a 48 hour fast before that, because you just want yourself so hungry that they'll basically
gobble up the chemotherapy, that's the idea.
So that's the whole idea, just to stick to a 24 hour fast, and then also consider doing